vous avez de bonsoir bonsoir j'adore
cette fille pas lui alors il y la bête
qu'un bon soir vous êtes journaliste sur
paris première elle france inter
écrivaine en 2002 la peau dure chez chez
grasset et aujourd'hui cette fille ouais
tu n'es pas la pilule amère pour tâter
jo on sait grâce et voilà et je crois
que cette fois ça y est le livre est
super bien accueilli non laurent qu'est
ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il ya et si tu
refuses de refuser me parler alors on
préfère regarder j'ai fait la grève de
la vanne ah ouais je n'en parlerai pas
pendant toute cette promotion
pourquoi j'ai eu droit moi aussi parce
que j'estime qu'elle a fait du mauvais
travail je veux pas le cautionner volet
travail qui veut dire de
la critique cinématographique elle a
fait un papier affligeant sur mon film
moi qui croyais qu'il y avait une bonne
vista l'a fait un truc à elle allait
devoir en mettez scatologique et
misogyne mais j'ai dit aussi que vous
aviez du panache non non pas de panache
si t'as fait ça met du film je déteste
c'est très
cohérent
non je vais faire pareil je vais porter
un jugement ynet et définitif sur son
lit et je vais dire qu'il est racoleur
et facile voilà je vais vous laisser en
parler ça sera sans moi merci
tulle avec ses biens alors donc
aujourd'hui vous publiez aujourd'hui
vous publiez tu n'es pas la pire attaque
quoi qu'il en soit
sur l'adoption bah oui c'est un truc sur
l'adoption se voudrait être c'est vrai
que c'est racoleur
points de base très bon accueil critique
en tous les cas alors je vais faire le
pitch
c'est un solidarité
dans le paysage est vous décidé
d'adopter une petite cambodgienne et à
partir de là le livre prend deux
directions il ya le récit proprement dit
de l'adoption avec les difficultés et
que ça entraîne évidemment et puis des
flash back sur votre histoire à vous sur
votre vie
la narratrice est secrètement amoureuse
de son père
un père qui gagne un jour phillies de
boutade tu n'es pas la fille de ta mère
est ensorcelé par cette phrase qui prend
tout son sens évidemment quand vous
adoptez cette petite fille alors la
question c'est pourquoi vous tel qu'on
vous voilà pourquoi adopter pour rester
vierge est tout simplement pour rester
vierge définitivement pour par choix par
choix serein tranquille sans doute est
la suite peut-être effectivement d'une
fixation
tendre et trop durable sur mon papa
enfin dans sa cdc les explications un
peu idiote parce que comme je le dis un
peu dans le livre mon horloge biologique
n'avait pas d'aiguilhe et que ce sont
des choses qui arrivent
un généticien à côté de moi qui est au
courant de toutes les réflexions qui ont
été menées sur l'instinct maternel sur
l'inné et l'acquis sur des philosophes
comme elisabeth badinter qui disait
effectivement l'instinct maternel c'est
quelque chose qui est plus culture 1 qui
voit là je vais pas rencontré le père
idéal c'est ça si cet enfant un père
mais le problème n'était pas tant le
père idéal que juste de faire un enfant
de reproduire voilà tout simplement des
femmes non non plus humain non je
voulais j'avais besoin j'ai besoin
d'élever des enfants mais je ne veux pas
les faire il ya cinq enfants dans le
monde il vous pouviez oui oui tout à
fait le savez des fois ça arrive qu'on
plein temps absolu vous êtes adepte de
la bible stérile dosettes en tigre 16 me
dit je suis un monstre temps ces
affaires de grossesse le dégoûte oui me
dégoûte en france assez une formule un
peu à l'emporte-pièce enfin me sont me
sont étrangères si je suis le fruit de
l'amour est le fruit précisément une
grossesse mais oui c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui m'est étranger vous
dit entendre la grossesse ressembler
pendant neuf mois à une barrique
variqueux non merci oui bien sûr encore
une fois c'est sur une idée non mais ça
vous dégoûter vraiment la sécu dans le
féminisme non non non non ça sonne donc
ça me dégoûte pas ça m'est étranger
c'est tout ça m'est étranger nombre
seulement étrangères jusqu'à du un avis
est décroché c'est très féministe est de
dégoût tu n'y est pas étrangère du tout
dans l'euphémisme quelques chansons
mépris de la mer qui est très importante
la pondeuse côté animal j'y suis est ce
que est ce que tu te rends compte que la
grande injustice de la planète que moi
je je je hurle chaque jour en me levant
le matin c'est de me dire mon dieu je
suis un homme et je ne porterai jamais
un enfant dans mon ventre voilà une
injustice totale quelquefois d'année en
suis un homme aussi et lacées de vous
arranger il faut vous entre vous oui
nous sommes deux hommes
gilson deux hommes s'est alors
elisabeth pourquoi pourquoi pas un
enfant blanc pourquoi un enfant
d'origine asiatique pourquoi pas un
enfant blanc
parce qu'il y avait quelque chose qui me
portait vers l'asie alors vous allez me
dire vous qui ne me connaissez pas oui
le cinéma vous avez ça une sorte
d'affinités voilà peut-être une histoire
d'affinités les enfants blancs vous
savez quand vous parlez d'enfants blanc
vont parler pourquoi pas en france
pourquoi pas adopter un enfant en france
parce qu'il ya très peu de trac ont
adopté parce que la france est un pays
très développés économiquement et que
tant mieux il ya de moins en moins
d'enfants adoptés et que les étrangers
affalé les français les adoptants il ya
vingt-trois mille familles ou individus
qui sont en possession d'un agrément
pour adopter cette année les familles
sont amenés à se tourner vers l'étranger
de plus en plus il ya une autre raison
du moins bon elle est allée à un tout
petit peu morale chez que dans
l'adoption il ya également choisir de
donner un
foyer un enfant qui existent déjà voilée
un enfant qui existe déjà et qui est
malheureux et qui probablement ne l'a
pas ses dimensions d'aller dans un pays
où effectivement ces enfants pourraient
être d'un orphelinat être abandonné à
une valeur morale qui remplace on a
redit créer et d'une certaine manière
aux projections qui est
logique mais il ya aussi le côté
consommateur c'est un enfant ça s'achète
comme le reste c'est ça un peu ça diront
oui mais pas les avocats du diable serre
on va dans un endroit où parce que c'est
ont souvent des associations j'ai fait
la même démarche que vous je suis en
train de finir le parcours de la das
pour adopter un enfant âgé j'en suis à
mon dixième entretien on a eu les
sociologues et psychologues donc je
connais le parcours mais à un moment
donné d'aller vers le tiers monde c'est
se dire il ya des associations il ya
beaucoup d'enfants il ya il ya un côté
quelque part on ne fait plus les enfants
parce que c'est un travail on se faire
par le tiers-monde et on se contente de
les recueillir comme on irait dans un
magasin acheter un objet déjà fabriqué
par le tir monde blanc vous nous l'avez
dit il je me suis mais bien non mais
vous avez raison de poser des questions
c'est une question que qu'on vous pose
et qu'on se pose on est amené à se poser
puisque on est dans une cantons
l'adoptent et quand on part adopter à
l'étranger muni de son agrément ce ce
viatique fragile et en même temps qui
ouvre surtout on est face à l'inconnu
c'est assez vertigineux et effectivement
j'avais cet élan cette affinité avec
l'asie je suis tombé lors de mes
démarches et mes rencontres avec des
gens d'associations sur une femme un
jour qui m'a dit pourquoi n'avez vous
pas au mali en ethiopie etc et je me
suis posé la question et j'ai été forcé
de me scrute et demandé de faire une
carotte morale à l'intérieur de moi même
c'est pas toujours très agréable et je
me suis rendu compte que je
j'allais me retrouver confronté aux
grands autres oui je suis trop
dépendante du regard des autres pour
adopter un enfant voire peut-être oui je
me suis effectivement interrogé dans le
pourtour de mon âme ce n'était pas
agréable comme autocritique mais c'est
une question qu'il faut se poser parce
que vous donnez un foyer un enfant il
faut le faire le maximum d'amour et de
confiance en soi simple vous raconter le
voyage l'arrivée à phnom penh que vous
appelez très joliment phnom penh
ville martin comme vous dites voilà la
difficulté de l'adoption le parcours du
combattant et dieu sait si c'est
compliqué dieu sait s'il faut en avoir
envie et quand on lit votre livre on le
voit en fait il ya un veto de la france
sur l'adoption d'enfants encore boggio
vous dites je me suis lancé dans une
adoption guérilla
pratiquement un an à une moment où le
cambodge était au bord d'avoir des
élections générales qui ont eu lieu et
où il y avait une sorte de quasi vide
juridique c'est juste avant que la porte
se ferme voilà j'ai pu évidemment il à
dimension mercantile de l'adoption les
pourboires les bakchichs les eaux france
étant que ces pays dans tous les pays
mais vous savez on donne de l'os
c'est une scène extraordinaire je dirais
comme les critiques de cinéma
oscarisable c'est le moment où vous êtes
dans l'orphelinat on vous attribue une
petite fille et ben oui bon voilà et
puis soudain vous en apercevez une autre
qu'au fin fond de la salle comme ça à
l'air d'être mieux
ça c'est balance était au plus mal a
choisi la pyrale a choisi celle qui
était couverte de d'arthrite les
premiers signes de la culpabilité et de
boutons de chaleur c'est à dire au mi6
avait cessé de prendre quoi celle qui
est joli quoi qu'il arrive c'est elle
qui mobilisait quoi qu'il arrive c'est
elle qui paye rase de toute façon donc
la fiabilité qui m'a motivé c'est vrai
que j'étais dans une pouponnière et
qu'on m'avait attribué comme on attribue
à tous les adoptant un enfant et que
c'était une petite fille que cette
petite fille avait un regard maman
pénétrant est triste et elle m'a regardé
et elle ne m'a pas violent fin et non
elle ne m'a pas choisi justement elle ne
va pas choisi et je me suis trouvé dans
un moment de solitude infinie face à un
enfant qui n'avait pas l'air de vouloir
de moi et j'ai vu juste derrière elle
une toute petite fille minuscule avec
des yeux très très très en colère vous
savez le regard sur l'île oui vous savez
ces yeux noirs qui vous perce et qui
vous disent des choses qui vous fige
vous êtes une statue seule solution
et l'autre la deuxième bien sûr elle m'a
choisi et elle a choisi elle m'a elle
m'a attiré pas je ne pouvais plus ne pas
répondre à ce regard le décès de sortie
du marché c'est pas mal le destin m'a
sorti du marché m'amener à la bourse
était un coup de foudre c'est le propre
du coup de foudre et je pense que dans
cette fabrication filiation qui est
l'adoption oui le coup de foudre existe
c'est précisément une très belle scène
se trouver parce que monzon cet enfant
pourriez le prendre partir avec et puis
vous voyez cette petite fille au fond de
la pièce il a fallu se battre pour cars
mené à bien l'adoption après oui parce
qu'après bon il ya le baby blues comme
après un vrai accouchement baby blues
l'administration il ya ce que
connaissent les adoptant ce que
connaissent les futurs adoptants un
parcours avec
des attitudes subtilement méprisante ou
suspicieuse de la part des gens dans les
administrations surtout en france
d'ailleurs qui vous vivez qui vous voit
et qui vous font qui vous donne le
sentiment d'être d'avoir une lacune
d'être insuffisant d'être sans doute
quelqu'un qui a eu un problème ou qui a
qui manque quelque chose ils vivent 1
qu' il manque une case à l'adoptant
cétacés a failli à des préjugés comme ça
c'est nasa c'est incroyable donc après
l'adoption il ya le baby blues vous vous
dites est ce que je veux vraiment de
cette étrangère d'un seul coup il ya une
période de flottement comme ça il ya une
période c'est tellement de moi d'espoir
d'énergie de rêve de d'appréhension et
angoisse et puis tout d'un coup on vous
met un enfant dans les bras vous vous
dire vous dit ça y est le mon destin ce
sel à ce destin c'est un nouveau jour
une nouvelle ère et puis vous retombez
enfin c'est comme si l'adrénaline
retombées et vous êtes hébété et tout ce
que vous vous dites est ce que c'est un
choix est-ce que c'est mon choix est ce
qu est ce que c'est la vie que je veux
enfin c'est un moment de flottement où
effectivement oui ce qui est fantastique
dans cette forme de filiation ce qu'il y
à un couple un couple qui se choisit un
couple qui se forme et bien évidemment
qu'on a un enfant naturel l'enfant a
ensuite à choisir ses parents c'est
naturel dans un premier temps c'est
fusionnel et puis ensuite il faut
accepter se choisir des parents ici
d'emblée comme un homme et une femme qui
se rend compte un enfants et sept femmes
seront cook et forment un couple dans un
moment d'amour fantastique c'est vrai
que c'est différent il n'y a pas mieux
et moins bien entre la filiation
naturelle et ça le sera aussi ce peut
être par ce regard là d'une beauté
superbe essai le même blouse qu'on a
qu'on vient de dire oui à sa femme ouais
tout d'un coup tu dis dans l'église oui
et après tu espèce de blues de ce que tu
dis merde est ce que j'ai fait je me
suis plié devant dieu là cette femme
jusque là je dis que je suis beaucoup
plus libre et on veut pas divorcer de
moi et puis aussi coutume toujours un
truc important il va une coutume grecque
qui semble vraiment
terrifiante maintenant mais qui
permettait aux femmes qui a tourné à
cacher d'un enfant qui est qu'ils n'en
voulaient pas elle le mettait en place
qu'ils ont des très nombreux endroits du
corps
et si personne n'en voulait le bébé
mouret si une mère l'éventuelle voulait
de cette enfant elle pouvait le prendre
au moins ils été choisis par sa mère
on le met dans des en allemagne par
exemple il ya les systèmes les femmes
qui va redonner un enfant le met dans
des petits berceau chauffer et dès que
la femme a déposé cet enfant de manière
anonyme il y un signal sonore qui
prévient le personnel soignant qu'un
enfant était abandonné donc ce système
par la grecque naturellement mais
existent dans de très très nombreux
endroits du monde d'accord alors il ya
effectivement ce baby blues et puis ya
aussi les difficultés de l'adoption on
se rend compte qu'il faut en avoir envie
quoi je versais jusqu'à la fin vous
attendait de savoir si vous allez
pouvoir repartir en france avec rentrer
en france mais ça c'était vraiment
circonstancielle lié à l'attitude de la
france vis-à-vis du pays pauvres le
cambodge d'un pays les plus pauvres du
monde ils ont le je crois que le revenu
national brut ses 280 $ à bittou enfin
jean-françois 4 me le dire mieux c'est
dérisoire il ya eu des trafics ya eu des
abus dans le passé au cambodge dans
beaucoup de pays du tiers-monde et du
sud est asiatique et les français de
façon généraliste est un peu rapide ont
décidé de mettre un moratoire et
d'arrêter tous évidemment les
orphelinats et les bébés trinquent dans
les bébés sont abandonnés donc voilà
donc l'adoption était un peu empêché par
les français je me suis battu
ouais pour pouvoir entrer pour voir un
visage d'enfant oui alors c'est un livre
très très touchant très bien écrit parce
que le style si on l'avait vu de la peau
dure et puis à cette conclusion ce bilan
vous faites à la fin ils s'appellent
tavril la petite fille vous dit tu avery
me rend meilleur ce ne sont pas les
enfants adoptés qui devrait être
reconnaissant
mais leurs parents oui toi tu as deux
phrases des sagesses elisabeth
lucidité n'aime pas jusqu'à la sagesse
je la réserve jean marie bigard il ya
une phrase formidable c'est ce soir je
sais enfin pourquoi je ne peux pas
mourir et oui je suis lié bien sûr je
suis lié non pas organiquement mais de
façon aussi forte et le jour où elle
vous demandera qu qui avait voulu
répondre à quoi la fille d'une mère qui
est sa mère biologique qui n'a pas pu la
garder qui à du lait mais puisque cette
mère a fait en sorte qu'elle survive
elle arrive dans un orphelinat qu'elles
soient nourris une ou deux fois par jour
pas beaucoup de bouillie autour d'une
bassine commune c'était déchirant à voir
mais une femme qui l'a suffisamment aimé
pour qu'elle puisse être adoptée par une
autre femme moi ouais voilà ce que je
lui dirai en français auquel sur votre
vraie semaine et il
n'y a plus d'état civil au cambodge
crois que seulement 20% de la population
peut déclarer les enfants parce que ça
coûte cher c'est une population
majoritairement rural et les parents
sont inconnus ses parents sont un non
même si c'était possible si elle te le
demande est à 16 en disant est ce que je
pourrai retrouver ma mère parce que le
cas se présente très souvent gens vers
16 ans qu'ils disent et si jamais je
retournais là bas et que j'essaie de
retrouver mes parents parce que ce soit
de toute façon une quête j'aurais peur
et je ris je l'aï permet ou pas si elles
veulent faire et bien face à jean louis
jean 16 ans il se serait passé des
choses oui j'aurais eu peur et je
l'aiderai bien sûr leur appliquer dans
ton sac à main
mais je l'aide et adopterait
lui cassera les couilles à lui dira
[Musique]
cet été
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu